I'm here in studio with a very special
guest from flown in from all the way
outside of Cologne Germany miss March
Ellis cell back she is a friend of film
courage and now a friend of David and
myself and we're pleased to have you in
studio with us how was it for you
sitting in on today's show as I've got a
little intense first of all thanks for
having me it's a great honor to be here
it was so much looking forward to it all
the time it was a great experience I was
very excited from sleep very well last
night but yeah I enjoyed it it was very
interesting for me inspiring and got a
lot of information and now I know where
you work um but what I wanted to know is
a when did you start with this and how
did it begin oh I like it she's turning
the tables on me I like it's good okay
we started this a year and a half ago
and it was initially an interview for
David and Gregor for a night before the
wedding and one of the actresses in the
film hey Gregor Collins is right there
as well as Phil Calderon and one of the
actresses larin lane from night before
the wedding she played one of the porn
stars at the bachelor party was supposed
to be there and unfortunately she
couldn't make the radio interview so as
a backup the host of the show Kip round
from
can set Karen watch you go ahead and
come on in studio and it was my first
time on the radio and I just fell in
love with it and so David and I after
the interview went home and we talked
about you know hey I'd be kind of cool
to have our own radio show and you know
I said well David if you're going to do
it then I want to do it too so it
started with that how this is how fifth
quarter was born yea big and so what do
you have planned for the rest of your
time you're leaving on Wednesday I'm
moving on wednesday i'm going to see
don't pull rice tonight with his rider
Edgar Michael Bravo oh yes a monophasic
oh yes and they're doing their new
project together there are mothers
Whitledge well that's right dress the
next project yeah and on Tuesday I'm
gonna see Korea here 94 year old
Austrian yes I'm looking for when he
talked a couple of times on the phone
with her wow it's good for me because
she speaks German in there yeah Ernest
well you'll enjoy meeting Maria she's
one of them yeah
looking forward to this very nice well
thank you again for coming out from
Germany we appreciate ledger and all of
your your tweets and Facebook posts and
you know just being so supportive of
everything that we've done